انتخابات الرئاسيه وبرلمانيه ربما تكون
الاهم في تاريخ تركيا الحديث وبعد عشرين
عاما يبدو ان اردوغان باتا على حافه
الهاويه وفق تقرير لصحيفه ساندي تايمز
فلاول مره يواجه اردوغان احتمال الخساره
حتى في معقله القديم طرابزون ومن المتوقع
ان يتراجع الدعم الذي كان يتحصل عليه
الرئيس المنتهيه ولايته لكنه لا يزال يحظى
بدعم ضخم بين قوائده الانتخابيه حيث ينظر
اليه باعتباره رجل دوله يحمل على عاتقه
مسؤوليه تحويل تركيا الى قوه عالميه لكن
شعبيه اردوغان تاثرت بعوامل عده بينها
نهجه الاقتصادي وفضائح فساد فضلا عن تعامل
حكومته مع الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب البلاد
في فبراير الماضي تقرير الصحيفه لفت ايضا
الى ان ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه في تركيا
باتا يغطي على كل شيء حيث سجلت معدلات
التضخم في البلاد ارتفاعا بلغت نسبته 85%
في اكتوبر وتمت عنصر اخر مؤثر في هذا
السباق الانتخابي بحسب الصحيفه هو ان نحو
خمس الناخبين الاتراك هم دون سن 25 ولم
يسبق لنحو نصف في هذا العدد التصويت من
قبل في وقت تشير استطلاعات الراي الى ان
نسبه كبيره من هؤلاء الناخبين الجدد تعارض
نظام الحكم السلطوي الذي ينتهجه اردوغان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات